welcome
everyone to the webinar how to pivot
your digital marketing to the new normal
expert tips and strategies presented by
simply learn
i'm your host stuart creek i'm a
marketing manager here at simply learn
and our guest today is a thought leader
in digital marketing matt
bailey a bit more about him in a moment
first a few notes on how to participate
in the webinar
you can use your controls at the bottom
of the screen on the left is your q a
question mark it will take you to the q
a box
where you can put in a question for matt
to address at the live q a
portion of the webinar towards the end
for chat questions during the
presentation
please use all panelists when you use
the chat
speech bubble
if you cannot find the question mark on
your
control panel the three dots will get
you to the question
an answer window and we will begin with
a poll
be asking you a few questions during the
presentation
about
how you're doing today and how you're
feeling
so let me begin with the first pull
first we'd like to ask what your current
role is
you're a student if you're working
professional if you're in management
and the second question in the poll
which you can answer at the same time is
how you're feeling today
i always like to ask that question
because we know it's a stressful time
when people are
still in the middle of the pandemic
crisis
and we'll give you about another 30
seconds to answer
all right please get your answers in and
remember to hit submit
a message from someone who can't hear i
will attend to that in a moment
you can see that people from
all different backgrounds all different
jobs are here today
from students on up to executives
and thankfully almost all of you are
feeling
at least okay most of you are feeling
better than that
we like to hear that and with that i
will introduce
matt
matt bailey
founder and president of sitelogic
marketing
also a digital marketing instructor for
the direct marketing association in new
york city
and an instructor for the online
marketing certified professional program
he is the author of internet marketing
an hour a day
wired to be wowed and teach an old dog
new tricks welcome matt thank you for
joining
us thank you stuart i really appreciate
the invitation to be here today
and looking forward to this uh
i tell you what the the subject of
today's session
is uh how to pivot to the new normal
and one of the first thoughts i had
about this
subject is well when we get to the new
normal let me know uh because
we have not reached it yet and i'm not
sure we're any closer to a new normal at
this point
uh because things seem to change monthly
uh as far as how we're going to deal
with this things that have to change
uh many businesses are choosing to
have people continue working from home
some are trying to move them back to
some
level of centralization but yet
i think people have learned that there
are many different ways
that we can pivot that we can change
that we can
uh adapt to these circumstances
and adapt as they happen uh what i love
to see is the resiliency
and the innovation that people have
shown throughout this
time uh and it's exciting to see
that we can handle anything and
so not as an invitation to more things
to happen
but i'm just amazed at how people
have adapted to this now from a business
perspective we do have to recognize that
things have changed buying trends have
changed
brand loyalty has changed
but it's all about the experience even
though
experiences have changed and we need to
understand
what consumers are expecting when it
comes to experience
and how that's going to play out into
their choices
so obviously businesses that aren't
digitally adapted they're going to have
to find a way
to adapt and get up to speed and improve
the experiences
uh without a roadmap many businesses
are trying to meet the needs of their
customers
there's no plan any content marketing
calendar has gone out the window any
product development
has maybe gotten sidelined because we've
all had to adapt
in order to approve improve and many
times most of us don't have that roadmap
in order to make it happen so we have to
improve
these experiences somehow
many times by trial and error to see
what works
or continuous improvement and adapting
to learning just as much as
consumers are learning and so it's
finding new opportunities and that's
what we're going to cover today
first and foremost we have all changed
the way that we
buy we've changed how we make decisions
uh for many people uh
you know i think when we start looking
at percentages
of people that have lost their jobs uh
families that have lost half of their
income or
maybe a great majority of their
income obviously it's going to change
priorities it's going to change the way
they buy
and it's interesting you can find
statistics and studies
all over about how this has affected
people
this one from mckenzie 80 percent of
consumers
say that the pandemic has changed the
way that they buy
they are looking at buying decisions
more closely
people are not just spending like they
used to
they are being more cautious about
spending money and about who they spend
that money with
not only that 86 percent of businesses
uh b2b has changed the way they purchase
uh and and 35 of both of them
more than a third of both businesses and
consumers
they are focused on price now that's
because
budgets are tightening everywhere and
it's very interesting even uh recent
studies
uh that uh just looking at email opens
from the beginning of the pandemic all
the way through till now
is that emails that focus on price and
discounts
are being opened uh more
uh when they're used in the email
subject line
than anything about corporate values
and this is going to be a theme
throughout uh
because the focus from a lot of
companies has been
about we're with you the corporate
values and and we're there
and people are not responding to that
uh in fact what we see is almost a
ridicule
or fatigue about brands
and and i'm sure if you haven't seen
this i recommend highly that you go
find it on youtube and the title of it
is
every covet 19 commercial is exactly the
same
what someone did here is they cut
together dozens of brand
commercials that all use the same music
the same camera angles the same focus on
the front line employees
and they use the same words
uncertain times we're here for you
people are our top priority and the
problem was they all
used the same persuasive tactics we call
that the pathos
the same emotionally driven
persuasive tactics to let you know that
the brand
is there in these trying times and when
it's done
we'll still be here and every brand
produced the exact same type
of ad uh and so what consumers
were being bombarded with these ads from
all the brands that were exactly the
same and
indistinguishable uh and what are they
really
saying uh and of course it's very easy
to get cynical about it they're saying
that
you know shelter in place but when
things lighten up go ahead and keep
spending your money with us
that's the cynical attitude and so
add to that uh you know the
especially here in the us uh the racial
situation
cr you know just increased because of a
few events
and that produced some riots that
produced protests
and then all of a sudden you had brands
pivoting from
we're with you and we're all in this
together
to an immediate pivot to we're for
racial justice where for
justice for all and not that that's a
bad thing that is a great
message people should be behind that
but the whiplash of pivot of brands
from covet 19 to
racial justice and then pride month
and the response of many many consumers
because this happened in a matter of
five to six weeks that these brands were
producing
commercials supporting all these things
and it creates what people were
calling this generic sympathy that the
brand is trying to be
everything to everybody and and uh
what is the product what are these
brands trying to do
what are they trying to present to us
um and recently i and i i'm gonna go off
script here
i just got an email with some articles
and i don't know what's happened to the
state of journalism
but here's the headline of an article
that was just sent out about two days
ago
and and here's the headline our mental
health
is deteriorating how brands can help
really i'm going to trust a brand to
help me with my mental
health i i it just
it blows my mind since when is a brand
responsible for this
and do i even want a brand involved
and why should a brand involved and how
can i trust a brand's motivation
because honestly their goal is to make
money
isn't isn't that the goal of any
business uh
and so pardon me for being a little
pessimistic about this
uh but here's the thing people want
information
they don't want to be pandered to uh
and here's a technology study just from
june
uh we keep hearing companies say that
we're in this together
but it falls short when they don't walk
the talk
that's the key companies need to help
customers come to that conclusion
on their own and that means that
companies are
saying all these things but we're not
seeing the evidence
of it they're saying that they care
about people but yet they put their
frontline workers at risk
and that's what we see and so what you
say
is very very different buying trends are
changing
what people are most concerned about
number one is their community their
local community
because they're seeing friends and
family that have lost jobs
they're concerned about their family and
friends the health
state of their family and friends
they're concerned about
finances uh this is a
that has asked what has impacted you uh
was this studies what has impacted you
and what are you concerned about
yes people are concerned about their
mental health their job their physical
health
look what's not in there look what
people are not concerned about they're
not concerned about brands
they're not concerned about these things
they are concerned about
if you're if you're familiar with
maslow's hierarchy of needs
this should not be a surprise maslow's
hierarchy of needs
is all about the i have to have a
certain set of needs
satisfied before i'm concerned about the
next
set of needs so for example at the
bottom level of needs i need to have
a place to eat i i need to i need food i
need water
i i need air i need these things to
survive at the next level
i need safety and security i need a home
uh a place to call my own uh
with my own possessions and then i need
family i need associations i need
friends
and and so when you look at the need
hierarchy that way
a lot of times what brands are selling
no one's buying
because we don't need that we're
concerned about other things
that have much more tangible
consequences
such as friends and family looking for
work out of jobs
concerned about kids going back to
school
many of us have bigger problems than
what's going
on and so because of that there has been
a drastic
shift in what people
are considering when they buy
and when they go shopping uh mckinsey
published this just a few weeks ago
that people are being more and more
mindful
uh and they are looking for value
uh looking here you can see a breakdown
of response
by country on average 40 percent
of consumers are becoming more mindful
of
where they spend their money
30 percent of customers worldwide are
changing to
less expensive products in order to save
money
and then uh big big differences here
uh so in in the us uh
uk about 20 of consumers
are doing more research on the brand
and product choices before buying uh
india and china are up around 40 to 45
of consumers are doing more research on
the brand and the product before buying
this is what is top of mind when it
comes to customers
this is what's top of mind is people
don't know what's going to happen
next month and because of that it
affects their decision-making about
how much they spend and reducing
spend and also being more considerate
about
who and what products they buy if this
is not first and foremost in your
business's
understanding of marketing then
your message will fall on deaf ears
because
these are the concerns that people have
all right uh yes stuart jump in
yeah if there are any questions i just
kind of
wanted to observe the fascinating
insight that um
in india the numbers are much higher
than they are in the united states for
example
yes mindfulness and concern over
you know researching what the brand
involved so it appears that indian
consumers
are better consumers than
u.s consumers are at this point
i mean it's a it's a very interesting
observation and i noticed that right
away that uh
yeah the response is you know being more
mindful
changing um you know and i think a lot
of that
you know it just depends upon your
situation where you are
um but i think even you know 40 percent
of u.s
and uk um that shows me
that the you know in a and what i would
describe as a more consumer-oriented
culture
um very very increasing very much
um whereas some of the you know other
european countries are not as much as a
consumer culture
uh so it doesn't affect them as much uh
that would be
you know my first but yeah that was very
interesting to see the breakdown by
country
uh i think putting it together would
have missed a lot of
insight on that yeah and one of our
guests asked is this last chart specific
to healthy lifestyle choices
well you know that is really a good
question
and i think the again when we when we
start talking about the
the shift in consumer attitudes
uh over the past six months uh
not only do we see a financial i think
we're seeing more and more also
uh people concerned about healthy
lifestyles
uh because now uh you know especially
those that are working from home
spending more time from home uh
it's now completely on you to
decide you know you're now in control of
your day
more than you've ever been before uh
you're in control of making your own
meals
and doing things like that uh you're in
control of your your physical
activity more than you've ever been
before so i think there is
more emphasis now uh on healthy
lifestyles healthy eating
uh and that will spill over then into
how i then
buy when i go shopping
yes if there are any questions feel free
to type those in
and uh i am i'm more than happy to
stop uh and answer some of those
questions as we go through
because uh uh we're going to cover a lot
of different types of content
so if you have a question go ahead and
put it in the box and we'll address it
as we go through the session
right right um i do want to remind our
audience
when you use the chat window if you
would direct your question to all
panelists
uh rather than the host the host is me
and um
for brad to see it or i'm sorry for matt
to see it while we're
in process sorry about that matt um yeah
that's all right i know you got brad a
couple times in here too
is to uh use the all panelist function
that will
bring it to his attention as well
and um what to
you'll see that you just got a question
in there
somebody is interested in the impact on
b2b
space for the usa market so let's go on
all right um now uh
in in the same study uh they did ask how
many shoppers
have changed to a new brand
or even change to a new retailer
uh since the pandemic 75
of us shoppers either changed a brand or
a retailer
that is huge i don't think we we've
ever seen this dramatic of a shift in
this short amount of time
ever uh 91 percent in india
have changed to a new brand or retailer
uh
i mean these numbers are incredible
the uh you know it just it goes to and a
lot of this is because of shortages
and so if your favorite brand or your
favorite product
was not available you tried something
else if the retailer you typically went
to
was out of a lot of things then you
tried somewhere else
people were moving trying to find basic
necessities
and so it forced people to move to new
brands
move to new retailers find new sources
of products that they
that were essential these aren't just
luxury brands these aren't just basic
consumer uh
purchases a lot of this was driven by
the need for essentials
and so this has been a shock to
a lot of brand marketing and i
i tend to believe that it has thrown a
lot of
assumptions about brand marketing uh
and a lot of theory about
how brands should market i think it's
turned
upside down because no one could have
predicted this
and its effects on how people are making
decisions
now here's what i said earlier
it's still all about the experience
it's all about the customer's experience
that has not
changed what has changed
is the definition of the customer
experience
and you see now the customer experience
is being driven by
value it's being driven by i want more
for my money
and so because of that i'm going to
research things
more in depth i'm going to plan my
purchases
uh and i'm looking for value
some customers have also said i'm
willing to spend a little more
if i get better value and so they might
be looking for more quality
but the experience now is not just
the brand experience and a lot of how
brand marketers would would focus on you
know
you know what's the customer journey and
how are they going to feel about our
brand
well you know what now it's driven by
value it's driven by price
uh and also what we're seeing
is there is also a rising sentiment
of how responsible is this brand
ecologically in with their employees
their employees safety
but also in social justice
uh we're seeing this a lot in the us
that brands are being
examined in a greater detail
about how much do they actually care
they say they care but how much are they
showing it uh are they are they taking
care of their local community
are they reaching out and are they
protecting their employees
like they they say they care about
people but what are they doing so
we're seeing a deeper level of a
consumer evaluation
of their experience to give you a a
great
example of this is especially nike
came out with a lot of ads about the
pandemic
uh encouraging healthy lifestyle
to do it yourself and then
uh with the the riots and the unrest
here in the us
nike then pivoted to a very strong
uh support of black lives matter and
social justice which is great however
a number of people started exposing
uh that nike's board does not have
a lot of uh racial makeup
it's primarily very very white
and then also nike offshores
a lot of its money so it doesn't have to
pay taxes
uh they they have headquartered their
company in such a way that they can save
billions of dollars in tax money well
that tax money would go
to the very people that they're saying
they're trying to support
and so now what we're seeing is this
rising sentiment against companies that
say they support but aren't showing it
and so what people want is a company
that cares for its employees
that contributes to the local economy
and
or to the general economy a company that
makes me
feel safe uh if we're going to shop
somewhere and they are not
instituting measures to keep people safe
uh then that's part of the experience
so it's not just value it's it's the
brand perception
it's what the brand is actually doing to
make me feel safe when i'm there
it's how they treat their employees and
it's all of these things
what a dramatic shift from just seven or
eight months ago
into the what what we would call the
brand experience
to what is now because now
we're in a situation that it's health
it's finances
its very basic needs and
we're evaluating things based on that
framework
not based on how pretty your brand is or
the music you're playing in your ad
those are irrelevant
all right let's take a little break i
know i've been throwing a lot of heavy
information out here
uh stuart i'll hand it back to you for
the poll
uh stuart i think you might still be
muted
thank you for pointing that out i i know
it's
it's it's the new normal is being muted
on a call
exactly um and if you check your chat
window
matt you'll see that there are some
interesting questions
all right i can't see the chat window
i'm
i will see if i can
and um meanwhile we launched
and this poll is what digital marketing
skills do you currently use in your work
so if you think about what you're
currently doing in your job
and you look at all the different
aspects of digital marketing which ones
apply to your current
as as the numbers are coming i can see
that social media
is by far and away the
largest category
keep the hole open for about another 30
seconds
and you have about 10 seconds to get
your answer in hit submit
so you can see that the
most popular answer is social media
followed by email
and then seo um but yeah
social media accounts for a very large
percentage of the audience
wow all right
let's go ahead all right
let me get back here i okay now i
figured out okay
here's the q a great all right
um let me see here some of the questions
that have come up here
um pharmaceutical and healthcare
industry um
i i would see yeah definitely this is
affecting pharmaceutical and healthcare
uh one of the things especially that i
think is opening up here
that i've seen in the u.s is there have
been regulations
lifted against telehealth
those regulations are being removed
which now enables
a number of people to now you know have
a video conference with a doctor or
physician's assistant
uh and finally uh
you know and i think a lot of people
were asking why were those regulations
in place to start with um so i think
that's that's part of the trend now is
we're
we're this is going to make health care
a little more accessible
to everyone uh so i i think we're seeing
more on that
um the pharmaceutical industry i'm not
sure other than
uh you know with this race to uh
you know a potential vaccine or
something like that
um it's going to be very interesting
because uh
you know pharmaceutical and healthcare
is seems to be at the center of
controversy
all the time uh so i think how they're
responding to
that and how they are presenting a
message is very very clear
um uh yeah and and
also in talking to brands part of the
the downside of this as well as what
we're seeing is
you know apple uh
ish great point apple becomes a two
trillion dollar company
amazon uh has ten years of growth in
six months um what we're seeing also
is because of the pandemic local
businesses are hurting
and international uh businesses
are growing because they have the
delivery mechanism
they have the things in place and so
what it has
caused is local businesses to have to
figure out a way to respond and i'll
talk a little bit more about that as
well
um
great question um so does this mean
the revenue of the companies will also
lessen due to mindful shopping of
consumers
as there will be no impulse shopping
that yeah absolutely
um you know i think what especially when
you see people
now a good majority of people are doing
online shopping at their local store
whether it's a grocery store or um
you know we have the the warehouse
stores and things like that where people
can go online
fill out their order and then go pick it
up and because of that you're going to
see probably less impulse shopping and
people staying on a budget
more uh and so yeah the revenue of some
companies have seen a
a downward trend uh because again people
are adjusting
their spending habits uh and so
that's that's definitely happening here
um
let me see a few other questions here be
move on
um do i think these points will change
after the election
oh god help us all um i don't
i honestly don't know um
you know as far as the u.s yeah just
throw that in there
um that's what i mean the new normal
we're not gonna hit normal for quite a
while
so i i don't think as long as there is
fear as long as there is fear as long as
there is
unemployment uh at these numbers um
is as long as there is uh
a chance of another lockdown uh that's
what
consumers are living with right now is
that they just
don't know um i i was fortunate enough
to
to have uh you know we met with some
friends of ours
uh she's a teacher and had her first day
of school
our kids went back to school today and
just in in the public school system she
didn't know
until friday uh what they were going to
be doing what the plan was
uh and then showing up on monday and
getting the plan
and finding out that her curriculum
wasn't ordered uh
you know there's there's just a lot of
uncertainty
there's a lot of people trying to make a
plan and the plan is outdated within 48
hours
uh so i i think a lot of these points
are still going to be
in place for a good amount of time i'm
not sure how much the election will
change at that
um so good question uh we'll see here
um and i'm gonna go ahead and move on
here a lot of the questions here we'll
uh address as we go through the session
but thank you so much for those great
questions
and i'll keep an eye on that as we go
through it
all right so how do we shift to
experiences especially in a local
business
and and one thing that we have seen is
people now are more willing to
focus on shopping local in investing
in their own community uh rather than
utilizing amazon or some of the big
retailers
uh because we we've become aware that
people are losing jobs in our community
businesses are having to go out of
business
uh and that affects the entire local
economy
and so more and more consumers are being
more focused
on building up their local community and
realizing and giving
especially local small businesses a very
wide allowance for making mistakes
because
they're everyone's shifting to this so
what we saw is an incredible
increase in delivery options in
self-checkout
uh contactless checkout or contactless
payment
uh also people are posting on facebook
or on instagram
whenever they see the employees are
being mistreated or expected to
to do something that's unsafe they're
publishing it around
and calling names of brands um now also
what brands can do and what you can help
people do
especially locally is if you are selling
something
make sure that you put your support
information online
so that if people buy something from you
locally
that they have the resources if they
have questions if they have
uh about that if they need instructions
the information instructions everything
is quickly available online
or that someone is available to talk
online
one thing that i've seen a number of
businesses do
is because employees are working from
home
they and also because many employees
they have
school-aged children so they either need
to take their children to school
or they need to make sure their children
are on
on their online school so regardless of
where the kids are going to school the
adults need to be there to
help them out or transport them and so
the company is then
allowing the adults to take the time off
in middle of the day to take care of
their kids
and then work a little bit in the
evening hours
and they're using those evening hours to
take care of chats to answer the phone
to feel available to their local
community or beyond
to answer questions in multiple time
zones
and so it's a great way now that they
are increasing
uh their communication and also working
with employees
to allow them to manage their homes
more more efficiently uh and so
there are great ways that people are
changing the experience uh and what we
need to look at is how we can look at
that end-to-end customer journey
it's changed dramatically and as i said
before no one knew how to plan for it
and now it's a lot of live exercise
go do it learn from it adapt it uh
that is one thing that uh if there's one
word that will describe
what your company can do is continually
adapt
adapt adapt figure out how we can create
a better experience
learn from it quickly and adapt again
don't stay rigidly uh in a new
experience or in a new customer journey
or or something new
learn from it find out what do people
like what's not working
and then quickly change it adapt it
figure out what works
those are the companies that will be
able to respond
great example of this uh is a company
uh down in missouri called the public
house brewing company and i think they
and
they are an example to what a lot of
local businesses had to do
uh they turned on and created curbside
and delivery service within three days
in order to survive that's what you do
now this is
interesting we had to implement the
technology
and infrastructure on the back end
to be able to track and collect all that
and do online ordering and here's the
key
it pushed everything forward maybe five
years
so here's a company that they had an
idea of where they wanted to be in five
years that hey this would be cool if we
do this
and all of a sudden the pandemic happens
and now their five-year plan turns into
a three-day plan
and that's what it forced and so a lot
of companies had to accelerate
moving online moving their uh
infrastructure online and it's very
interesting because
uh i think late last year i was looking
at a study
that 30 percent of small local
businesses
30 percent did not think that having a
website was important
and that was less than a year ago that
that study was made
now what we're seeing is not only is a
local
website presence important it's now
critical
to people being able to find you ask
questions
uh order uh shop
contact you it's critical and for many
many businesses
it moved up those plans by years
into implementing them within days uh
and so that's a
heavy fast pivot that people have had to
make
well here's some of the data if you
haven't been on google trends
i highly recommend that you do so
because google trends is going to show
you some really
amazing things about how people have
pivoted
during the pandemic number one
uh if you look at the let me see if i
can get my drawing tools here
annotate good all right uh
number one home improvement and
here is june 2020 uh
and beyond uh let me see right about
here is march march 2020 when the
lockdown started worldwide
and look at how much uh searches within
the home
improvement topic increased
uh over the the pandemic and they
continue to increase
same thing here uh baking uh
now this is within the united states and
the two times that baking peak
during the year in the u.s you probably
know uh
is thanksgiving and christmas uh those
are the two times of the year that
people bake
but look at what happened in march when
people started staying home
and right now one of the one of the
products
that uh is hard to find is
flour because so many people started
making their own bread
at home they started baking more and
making more
uh things at home and so the flour
industry
is really the baking industry is seeing
an incredible change
and now think about this people are
learning to do this more at home
uh youtube videos of people learning how
to do home improvement
how to bake how to cook how to sew uh
how to do things around the house to
become more
self-sufficient uh gardening
has increased uh people looking for
seeds
in order to grow more vegetables at home
this has changed
a drastic shift to becoming more
independent
and becoming more self-sufficient and
not depending
on the the food supply chain
or depending on retailers to provide
what we need
and so the experience has changed to
people looking more and more
anything that had to do with the house
where people live
improvement or anything like that saw a
dramatic increase i'm going to show you
some more of these
uh towards the end of the session uh
of just an amazing way that
that uh the pandemic shifted the
interests of people in what they were
concerned about
now obviously businesses had to pivot
like i said
a year ago 30 of small businesses did
not think that having a website was that
important
well shopify has reported that they
doubled their consumer base in three
months
uh their revenues doubled uh
from the same quarter in 2019 uh the
number of stores
on shopify alone increased by 71 percent
how often do you see a business double
uh
within three months uh and what it was
driven by
local brick and mortar retailers moving
to online platforms
uh and even traditional brands
uh who just had a brand presence
uh and sold through retailers they
also started opening storefronts as well
where people could
buy uh from the uh
from the brand direct rather uh
than just uh you know going through
retailers or anything like that
and so online e-commerce platforms
all saw significant growth primarily
from brick and mortar retailers
moving online uh so
now consumers are adopting i wish i had
a better
graphic of this here's our how
consumers are adapting and what
behaviors we're seeing here
and this is from e-consultancy uh
consumer behavior number one consumers
are adopting uh digital features much
faster
and it's not this they're adopting them
uh what they're also seeing is consumers
are demanding them
uh especially those consumers that are
high risk in this pandemic
and they're not going out they're not
going to go to your store
if you're not accommodating them uh even
around me there are many stores that
still have
high risk shopping times so if you are a
high risk uh
beca you know with your health or
anything like that
you can go from six to seven in the
morning and do your
shopping uh and they have distancing in
place they have
uh it's after the store has just been
cleaned all night
uh and you know you wear the mask and
you don't have to be around a number of
other people uh
and so consumers are demanding this
uh and they're expecting it and so right
now
if you've ever thought about moving more
digital products or processes online
now's the time to do it because
consumers are adopting those changes
very very quickly uh now also what we
see a change in customer journey
again it's not because uh b to b
and b to c have chosen to do it it's
because it was
necessary to survive
so of course there's been changes in
customer journeys
and consumers are adapting to it because
they recognize this as well
uh but here is some of the the middle
one here is probably one of the biggest
things that i think is affecting
us and it will affect for a long time
and that is
consumers both b2b and b2c
are delaying major spending
decisions that's huge
that is absolutely huge and
so not only do we have significant
amounts of the population
around the world out of work
we also see consumers that do have the
money b2b companies that do have the
money and some that don't
uh they're putting off major spending
decisions again because of
uncertainty and if you aren't
recognizing that uncertainty in your
marketing
then more than 50 percent of consumers
won't understand what you're trying to
say in fact they may resist it
uh because you're not providing that
empathy
that people are choosing not to spend
so this is a significant significant
change
and again whenever we get to the new
normal
let me know uh because i don't see these
things
changing very much until this is
completely done and even then we're
going to have some after effects
uh that probably are not planned for
now one of the things if you've ever
been to china
i one thing that absolutely amazed me
and this was about 10
years ago when i was there why haven't
we done this earlier in the us
or more around the world uh in the u.s
we're still
in love with the menu that you get
handed that everyone else has touched uh
when i went to china 10 years ago
there's a qr code on the table
you take a picture of the qr code and
you get the menu on your phone
you choose what you wanted and you could
pay
through the app fantastic it was just
absolutely amazing
and just over the weekend i i took my
family out to eat it was kind of like a
celebration before school started
they had the qr code i could see the
menu
it didn't work that well uh and then the
uh checkout uh or or the payment feature
that didn't work either that's not going
to be acceptable
uh so and how do you get around that
well here in the u.s i still had to give
them my card i still had to
touch the pen just to sign that doesn't
make people feel
safe that's not adapting to the new
customer journey that's
that's still relying on the old customer
journey to complete a task
when in reality the technology is there
now i've tried this a number of times
more and more restaurants and more
places are implementing this qr code
to show the menu but the problem is
the navigation isn't good the display
isn't good and it's this rush
to get online but in the rush to get
online
you're not iterating and improving
you're simply doing it
without testing and so so many times
if you're going to do this think about
number one how can we replace paper
how can we replace unnecessary contact
i love the qr code i love doing that but
if you're going to do it
make sure it works um
now this is what i mean number one this
is called friction
if i use your qr code and i bring up
information on my phone if it doesn't
work right
if i have a hard time finding the
information i want
if it does not if it does not
flow easily through my task
and onto task completion that is called
friction
friction stops me from browsing
because i can't find things because i
can't understand the menu
it stops me from shopping and checking
out because
i'm not confident or it times out
or it doesn't recognize something and
then
uh am i updated on the delivery
do i know what's happening do i have a
visual order confirmation
you see a lot of people are pivoting and
adapting and creating these new paths
and creating these new journeys
but they're not testing them they're not
going through them themselves
or are they asking other people to test
the best thing you can do
if you create a new digital journey is
to test it
look for those friction points and as i
said before
continue to iterate adapt test
remove friction because if people are
looking for you and they want to use
your services
but it is difficult to do so on their
mobile device
they will they'll stop they'll leave
they're not going to continue through a
process that frustrates them
especially when there are other brands
or other companies that will offer a
better more optimized process
people right now are trying to eliminate
stress from their lives
and if your app or your process creates
stress
that's going to be a problem so test
and then as you're creating an app if
you want to create an app if you want to
create
uh a process your number one question
should be
what problem will this solve don't just
create an app to create an app
think about the problem you're trying to
solve first
make sure you talk to customers make
sure that they
agree with you that this is a
significant problem that needs to be
solved
and that it is the primary problem that
needs to be solved
i've worked with a number of companies
where they think they're going to solve
a problem
and then when they talk to the customer
they realize that customers
think that there is another more
important problem
that the brand needs to solve and so
you need to justify this and not just
with the customer
but throughout the organization make
sure there's agreement
on the problem that needs to be solved
and how it will be
solved other than that you're just going
to create an
app that does something and
it may not take care of any problem so
clearly identify what problem it's going
to solve and
and if this is the right solution
outline it implement it iterate it
test it and continue to develop it
and improve it uh don't just create
something
and set it out there and expect people
to know
how to use it i this is where i love
just that
the dynamic development um the agile
development
start with the basics make sure it works
and then continue development
continue to test continue to improve and
add as
necessary don't just get it out there
and tell people that we have done
our digital pivot uh that's not good
enough
uh it absolutely needs to take into
account
that you didn't do it right the first
time very rarely has that happened
and so continue to iterate and develop
all right then as you iterate and
develop
invest in usability testing now this can
be as simple as just getting
a number of people who don't work for
you to complete the task
and watch them and listen
don't direct them watch how easily can
they complete this
uh how often are your forms tested
and do you know who gets the the form or
the email
uh do you i have you identified the
obstacles in the process
uh and it just the people that you test
with
they need you they need to answer the
questions is it simple is it easy
is it clear and my ultimate question for
a usability tester
does this make you happy uh that's
that's the question i want
if you've never been involved in
usability testing uh
i it is the most eye-opening thing
you'll ever be a part of
uh because you want testers that are
honest
and i've seen brands in the room when
testers will
say this is the worst thing i've ever
tried i can't accomplish this i don't
understand
and because in our own organization
we tend to look at our own products more
favorably
we tend to think that people understand
what we're trying to say
when in reality we have our own language
we have our own processes
and when we create an app or when we
create a process
people outside of that don't always
understand it
and so it needs absolutely to be tested
and that's the best way that you can
pivot
uh also uh as part of any process
let people know how far they are and
give them
confirmation that they have successfully
completed the task
i have been amazed uh at how many
companies
uh we have through this pandemic uh
health companies uh asking people to
fill out forms online and it is
impossible
to complete uh and then when it is
completed it seems like
no one has seen the form uh and they're
asking the same questions again
uh school registration forms terrible
people aren't getting through them they
don't understand
them or the form stops working i'm
amazed at how many organizations that
require this type of questionnaire or
content
i have to ask if they've ever if anyone
that works for the organization
has ever tried to complete it uh
again the importance of having people go
through this
but also you need to let people know
that they have done things well
and they have reached success as they go
through the process
so eliminate that friction in all your
online interactions
that will reduce the stress and that
will give
consumers a reason to come back and work
with you
uh now when it comes to the customer
journey
uh again we were all forced to change
our customer journeys
and it will change again uh
prepare for a post pandemic customer
journey
whenever that happens how will you react
if things go back to normal
because they're not going to be a great
normal or the same normal it's going to
be a different normal
but how can you prepare for that but
also
now that you've been through it how can
you prepare for another potential
pandemic
journey uh if there's another lockdown
two years from now
will you be prepared what will you do
and so
now part of our planning not just has to
be for
right now or for a year from now it's
if this is the new normal if they're
and many epidemiologists are saying
they're
the chances of this happening again is
very good
so how will you react how you plan for
it and how will
you adapt your company to
ongoing changes in consumer attitudes
uh just a couple of things with
innovation a lot of people are
starting new businesses a lot of
businesses are pivoting
and i want to show you some things out
of google trends
that have been absolutely incredible to
see
number one the rise in
home tutoring uh people are not
don't feel safe with their kids going to
school
uh and so they're looking for private
tutoring and home education
telehealth has increased dramatically uh
it's almost to a level now where it was
double what it used to be
uh home gyms home fitness look at the
the trend has been around here and then
it
r skyrocketed three times what it used
to be
and now it's leveled off at double uh
what the demand used to be uh same thing
with home and garden
baking and delivery services
look at google trends it's going to tell
you where consumer attitudes
are what they're looking for and
potential methods or
ways or areas that you could pivot your
business into
in order to take advantage of these
changing
times all right still i'm gonna hand it
back to you for the last full
and some q a great great
and our last poll is the same as the
previous poll but now we're looking at
what you would like to learn
looking at that same set of skills which
ones are you not currently using that
you want to add to your toolkit
while people are doing this there was a
good uh question that came in
um that was in india people are focusing
on
self-reliance and localization do you
think that's the reason for changing
brands
and i would say absolutely yes and not
just in india
i think that's happening worldwide that
people have seen the supply chain break
down
and they've seen the uh the impact on
their local communities worldwide
and so i think that's the reason we're
seeing changing brands we're seeing more
people
i like how you said that they are
focusing on self-reliance and
localization
uh they're seeing the importance of this
because of the pandemic
yeah that's been a trend in the united
states off and on for
many many years with the phrase by
american
and it kind of faded back
over the last decade as more
work was flowed uh
offshore more manufacturing was sent to
china
but within the last several months
we've heard um a lot of talk
from both political maine political
parties here
about the need to buy america
so it is a phenomenon that's happening
lots of differently and it is
interesting because it's still an
emphasis on buying
um it's and i heard someone talk about
this the other day they're like the
emphasis is still on consuming
they still want us to spend money uh and
consume
uh what no one's asking is is it
necessary
uh you know what we need to spend the
money on is it necessary
is it good is it helpful um
and and what i'm liking what i'm
enjoying more is people that are
focusing on the buying local
um what do i need that can be satisfied
locally
rather than uh you know going more to
amazon
um and you know so i while amazon has
increased dramatically i think a lot of
people are starting to reevaluate that
in their choices and the results of the
poll are in the most popular answer is
an overview of or all skills become
basically a t-shaped marketer
phrase of adding a broad range of
understanding of all the different
pieces
even as you specialize or become an
expert in one
wonderful thank you and that brings us
to our q a
proportion of the webinar proportion
portion of the webinar and that's good
to see on the poll
i mean all these skills are interrelated
uh
you know anymore it's you know you're
using
seo and social media and paid you know
all these things together
uh across all channels and adapting your
content
on each channel uh to drive people to
your website
so yeah it's it's a an integrated
profession here so good to see that
let's move on
that does bring us to the q and a part
of our
webinar we've got a bunch of questions
in from the audience and i'm going to
start off with um
one on career um priyanka asks
since i'm still in the early stages of
learning digital marketing
i need to understand what the role of a
digital marketer than normal is as far
as job prospects
that's really really good so there and
that's the thing is i was just talking
about the all skills they're so highly
integrated
uh and it's interesting that question
came up the other day what is a digital
marketer
and what skills make them up when i had
my agency
one thing i challenged all my new
employees to do
was to spend about a week with different
specialists so spend a week with the seo
spend a week with the paid
search spend a week with the web uh
website managers or designers
um you know learn some of the different
disciplines that are going on
but the first and foremost most
overriding skill
that i looked for in a new employee
was the ability to write and speak
well uh if you can
write well then you can work in seo
in paid search in email in social media
and in website development
because the need for well-written
quality content is the biggest need
uh that companies have and if you have
that skill
you can learn anything else very quickly
and easily
uh but most people do not have that
skill of written and verbal
communication
and that is what i would call a core
core skill for any marketer
yeah it's a it's a core skill really for
anyone in any profession that's a good
point
i mean and one of the aspects
that people sometimes forget
is internal or inbound communication
being able to tell your co-workers and
your boss what's going on
not just uh yes customers
um the question from such and related
is in today's scenario digital marketing
education is widely available
and there's a lot of people involved in
digital marketing so what qualities can
make me stand out from the rest in that
area
um well i would i'm still going to
default to
uh communication um because as you said
it's both external with client facing
and it's internal with stakeholder
facing
uh and other people so and i see this a
lot especially people
you know uh analytics is one area
where i see that there are a lot of
skilled and talented people that
understand analytics uh but then they
need to
present their findings in a way that is
persuasive
in order to have a decision maker or
stakeholder approve
their recommendation uh and so there's a
lot of
internal work that goes on and so
you know i highly recommend people
number one those communication skills
number two
understand how search engines work
number three analytics
being able to understand how things are
measured and how they affect
each other uh understanding that
holistic view
of digital marketing uh and then that
will allow you to specialize
uh but i think sometimes too many people
will specialize in one area
and that will limit uh your ability if
you can't adapt quickly
uh if you focus just on uh
you know for example paid search and
that's all you focus on but then you
don't
learn the principles of search engine
optimization
which are very similar and can be used
but if you don't learn that
then you're not going to be able to
adapt you're not going to be able to
manage
others and it will limit your prospects
for uh
for promotion um there's
several people interested in b2b
one question is
how the effects that you're
talking about impact the b2b space
specifically in business process
outsourcing
well i yeah b2b is seeing a lot of
dramatic
shifts in budgets uh like i said number
one they're re-evaluating major
purchases
so that is being removed out of there
and because of that
uh advertising and marketing budgets are
being drawn down as well uh
not a surprise if there's less people
interested to buy then
that that's naturally going to affect so
i think there's
what we're going to see is people
repositioning the value of their
products
um you know we're going to have to sell
things better
based on their value uh rather than just
based on a brand name
it's what am i getting with this and am
i getting my money's worth
uh people also may be looking for
substitutions
that i can't afford this you know fifty
thousand dollar
software uh but is there some
up and coming company uh that may be
selling it for a fraction of the price
that will allow me to do half of what i
need to do
um so that's where a lot of b2b
companies are going to be doing
is they may not then looking
for a full solution uh but a partial
solution that costs
much less and so there's opportunity
there for
small b2b vendors uh there's
and it's all going to be in how you're
positioning and what
value you're providing okay
um i have a question
that came in from rajan in south india
50 000 shops closed in one of the
districts
alone almost 10 lakh which is about a
million
jobs
what the what aspects of digital
marketing are going to
help recover these
or how can people
look to wow repair that damage
through digitization
i wish i had the answer to that that is
uh i
i mean that is we're seeing that
everywhere um
i don't think and the thing is i don't
think governments know
um because they don't understand digital
marketing
uh so don't rely on them uh it's going
to
take you know a combination of
people optimistically searching for
innovative solutions and ways that
they can change their business um
that's what it's going to take it's not
something that everyone's going to be
able to do
uh it's it's i i
you know i think we see this every time
there's a recession uh
that what companies were founded during
recessions
and became successful um
and you know apple was not really
doing that well until they came out with
the ipod in the first recession
uh you know around uh in a recession
around the year 2000
um but people wanted it and they were
willing to spend their money on it
and so i was going to say facebook i
think the
dates from the 2009 recession yes
yeah um so it's it's you can't always
predict that just because things are bad
everything's bad you can always find a
niche or an
opportunity um i can't speak to
you know the millions of people but
maybe some of those owners
will be able to find ways
to meet their customers where they are
we have time for our last couple of
questions a few people asked about the
education
market or the education sector
pierre asks uh working for
a training center for managers so what's
the future of education for
professionals is there still a place
for physical classes or is everything
going into e-learning
well right now everything's e-learning
uh and so
for education professionals um
it's going to be you for an education
professional you are going to have to be
skilled for both in-person
and digital delivery uh and that means
learning and adapting your skills to
presenting online
teaching online uh and learning
different methods
of online education
uh i just recently went back to school
and got my master's degree
in uh instructional design and
educational technology uh
because as an instructor of digital
marketing i
wanted to do it better i did not know
the pandemic was happening
when i signed up for these courses uh
but what it did teach me
was how to better structure online
lessons
how to better teach and create
activities with real world application
and even now i'm teaching courses online
and i'm still learning how to refine
those activities
because some sometimes they work great
sometimes they don't uh it's it's a
matter of
constant learning as an educating uh
professional i i'm constantly learning
what is going to work best in this
digital format
uh and so and and also again
adapting sometimes your camera's on
sometimes it's off sometimes you have 30
people sometimes you have five
uh what is going to be the best method
to teach this specific content
uh teachers everywhere are going to have
to learn
both in classroom and online skills
as well as the tools for online delivery
which those tools can be just as
difficult as teaching itself
so that is the future of education
but i also see opportunity for those
that can teach
well online and
as parents many parents are opting for
homeschooling
and they're looking for teachers that
can assist them
and there are many teachers right now
that have created
a new uh really a new demand and a new
profession and that is online tutoring
and online teaching
and uh just doing it all online
for parents all over the world and so
that is uh
you know again there's different
opportunities opening up all over the
place
you know in professional education we
simply learn of
if found that um
you know there's a great deal of
additional interest in
what we're doing um and
using simply learn as a way to prepare
for advancing your career
when the lockdown is over if not
during this period of pandemic and
adapting to it um
one last question is kind of a synthesis
of a couple that came
in
what is the role of things like data
science and artificial intelligence
in the future digital marketing
well uh if if you'd asked me that
question six months ago
um i would tell you that you know
it would it would save our time save
time
and the best way to look at machine
learning and artificial intelligence
is more like uh the best uh uh
reference that i saw it's like having a
million interns
rather than one smart ceo
because machine learning ai and
marketing
they're going to perform a lot of the
small functions the the hundreds or
millions of little small
functions uh very very quickly
uh but they're not going to provide
major
technology or decision shifting content
uh there they are going to make
connections they're going to see the
patterns but ultimately
it's on the marketer to interpret that
information
and derive a course of action and then
again
the machine learning is only going to be
as good as the data that is put in
all the machine learning and ai fell
apart as soon as the pandemic happened
because we had no data and so what was
there to learn
and so six months ago i would have
answered that very very differently
now i'll say that you know as things
change
uh machine how is machine learning going
to adapt to
a need for increased empathy in
marketing communication
uh how is that reflected in the
measurement
and in the association so
it's going to have a place i in some
places
it it makes much more sense than others
it will it becomes something that is
central to the marketing workflow uh
and and can't be separated from it i
think we're years away from that
and and even still like i said it's
dependent upon
uh the quality of data
that has been given uh in order to
reduce bias but uh when
data is absent it makes it even that
much more difficult
yep um yeah data is
obviously the the raw material for
machine learning but it's also the
it's also the mind from which you
extract insights about
customer behavior about
demand about trends
so science and
machine learning artificial intelligence
are
both inextricably
linked to the future of uh digital
marketing
yeah and i'm just going to throw in a a
bit of an opinion i
i think there's there's value in looking
and watching
at what data science and machine
learning can do uh but i will say the
companies
that are in love with that shiny
object that they are pursuing that these
tend to also be the companies that don't
test their processes
that don't test their apps that don't
iterate
the the journey and the process that
people go through
and if they did they would see dramatic
increases in profitability they would
see dramatic increase in revenue
but instead of doing simple things that
will
improve processes and make customers
happy
they are focused on shiny things that
will cost a lot of money
and reduce their profitability that's
what i tend to see
in a lot of companies and so i would
caution against that
and again readjust the focus on what
we're doing right now
and how do we make it better yeah
they're tools not magic wands
good point okay there are a lot of other
questions
we couldn't get to and i'm afraid we're
out of time for those but
this has been so very informative matt
thank you thank you a lot of the
comments coming in have been
very appreciative so i think we're at
the end of the presentation now
yeah i'd like to thank you matt and
i ask you to let people know how to get
in touch with you
sure uh my website is sitelogic.com it's
right there on the screen
uh and then also connect with me on
linkedin uh that is my primary
social network that's where i do most of
my posting
uh but if you go to the website i also
have a podcast
uh that you can subscribe to
and uh we're coming up on our 50th
episode
of the podcast um it's taken me about
three years to get there
uh but we are slowly coming up on it so
uh i would be flattered and uh humbled
if you would find value in the podcast
and the content that i post
thank you stu i really appreciate the uh
the opportunity to present today
well we've been very very pleased to
have you
and um we're very pleased to have
everybody here in the audience um matt
if you go to the next slide
i'd like to remind people that we do
have
another uh webinar coming up
next wednesday at the same time 9 p.m in
india 11 30 a.m on the east coast of the
united states
check your time zones elsewhere this
expert webinar is
how to build a successful data analytics
career
in retail banking and finance sector
and our guest is the chief analytic
officer of lending card abhishek singh
i hope to see you all next week for that
and remember you can keep in touch with
simply learn on
our social channels as well
we have facebook twitter and linkedin
and we look forward to seeing you
at future webinars and having you
join our family of learners
thank you again this is the end of the
webinar so please at this time log out
and you should be
then presented with a survey uh if you
take a moment to answer those questions
it would be very helpful
good day and good evening
you